je n'avais jamais rien vu d'aussi beau
j'ai joué à Tetris pendant à peine 5
minutes mais je vois encore des blocs
tombés dans mes rêves c'est de la poésie
l'art et les maths collaborant dans une
boule versante harmonie c'est le
jeu parfait
triste
pourquoi ce nom
c'est le mélange du mot grec TETRA qui
veut dire 4 et du mot tennis tennis le
créateur russe est fan de tennis
ce jeu n'est pas juste addictif il
s'installe littéralement dans votre tête
c'est le genre d'occasion qui ne se
présente qu'une fois dans une vie il n'y
a que des autres personnes dans le monde
qui ont vu ce que vous allez voir
ça s'appelle la Game Boy vendez-la avec
Tetris vous pouvez nous avoir le droit
l'Union soviétique détient les droits
internationaux rien ne sort facilement
je vais à Moscou vous allez entrer dans
un pays communiste qui considère encore
l'Amérique comme son ennemi numéro 1 ok
le qui feriez mieux d'en parler à votre
femme d'abord les visionnaires
doivent tout risquer pour gagner pas
assez conditions
est-ce que notre appartement a déjà été
aussi silencieux
voici le créateur de Tetris votre jeu
est fantastique je ferai de vous un
millionnaire monsieur Rogers vous avez
déjà négocié avec les Soviétiques on est
là pour Tetris
[Rires]
c'est un membre du Comité central du
Parti communiste parce que tu es une
menace vous savez où se trouve votre
mari qu'est-ce qui se passe bordel le
monde est en train de changer messieurs
et il est hors de question que l'Union
soviétique passe à côté de ses
transformations c'est comme ça que le
monde fonctionne où est mon argent mais
on marche sur la tête on pourra pas vous
protéger parfois vous devez dire aux
chocs
on y va allez allez allez
ça c'est criminel
Union soviétique et sur le point
d’imploser il manque tout le monde ment
rentrer chez vous la cavalerie rappelée
on n'a pas le temps ça va aller
c'est pas vrai vous êtes vraiment les
rois du suspense
[Musique]